y
[Música]
el expresidente hondureño juan orlando
hernández se entregó a la policía del
país luego de que eeuu le pidieran
extradición por supuestos delitos de
narcotráfico cometidos entre los años
2004 y 2012 enlazamos a tegucigalpa
el príncipe andrew de reino unido llegó
a un acuerdo con virginia y sufre en la
demanda en la que se le acusa de haber
abusado sexualmente de ella cuando tenía
17 años el acuerdo incluye una donación
millonaria del hijo de la reina isabel
2a a la fundación de joffré ampliamos
desde nueva york
y el canciller alemán olaf scholz dio la
bienvenida a la retirada parcial de
tropas rusas en la frontera con ucrania
anunciada por su homólogo ruso vladimir
putin mientras que el presidente de eeuu
joe biden dijo que no ha podido
verificar el repliegue de las tropas
rusas
bienvenidos de nuevo a un informativo de
france 24 soy rodrigo serán hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos empezamos en honduras
porque el expresidente hondureño juan
orlando hernández se entregó a la
policía para ser detenido a la puerta de
su domicilio tras la petición de
extradición de eeuu por supuestos
delitos de corrupción y narcotráfico la
semana pasada a las autoridades
estadounidenses ya habían suspendido el
visado de entrada del ex mandatario al
país para ampliar la información
conectamos con nuestra corresponsal en
tegucigalpa que ni a torres que ni a qué
pasos pueden seguir a esta detención y
cuando sería enviado el expresidente a
eeuu
rodrigo que nadie como estas de salud o
bueno en este momento el expresidente de
honduras juan orlando hernández
es un preso está ya en manos de la
secretaria de seguridad está en manos de
la justicia hondureña quiero más o menos
comentarte cómo se dio todo este proceso
no fue necesario que la policía lo
aprendiera dentro de su residencia él
salió a la puerta de su residencia con
un chaleco antibalas también con una
gorra y aparentemente lucía tranquilo e
inmediatamente el jefe de seguridad le
puso le colocó grilletes y además pues
cadenas en sus manos después de este
acto se pensó que iba a ser trasladado
al batallón donde se encuentra en este
momento ya en calidad de preso en un
helicóptero hubiera aérea sin embargo se
subió fue subió a uno de los vehículos
de la dea y encuentra en la dado vía
terrestre es un trayecto corto
rápidamente ya él fue ingresado al
batallón donde fue presentado ante los
medios de comunicación en calidad de
preso que sigue de ahora en adelante
pues el juez estará con él en lo que se
llama una audiencia preliminar donde él
conocerá sus derechos y por supuesto se
le dará a conocer porque ha sido
aprendido cuando será el proceso de
extradición pues todavía no se sabe nada
hay que cumplir primero con todo este
procedimiento y el juez determinará si
lo extradita de una vez por todas a eeuu
gracias kenia por seguir con nosotros
todo este proceso y por esta información
vamos a eeuu porque una corte de
manhattan anunció un acuerdo entre el
príncipe andrew y virginia sufre la
demanda en que se le acusa de haber
abusado sexualmente de ella cuando tenía
17 años el acuerdo incluye una donación
millonaria del hijo de la reina isabel
segunda del reino unido a la fundación
de joffré sin el monto nuestra
corresponsal en nueva yor mamen sala no
se ampliaba esta información
si el príncipe andrés de inglaterra
acaba de llegar a un acuerdo económico
extrajudicial con virginia new free
quien le había demandado por abuso
sexual así lo acaba de informar a través
de un comunicado hace menos de una hora
el tribunal de manhattan que está
llevando este caso virginia giuffré
demandó al príncipe andrés por abuso
sexual en ese entramado de tráfico
sexual de menores del multimillonario
fallecido jeffrey epstein y el principio
andrés lo ha negado siempre pero ahora
van a poner fin a este proceso con este
acuerdo entre ambos según un comunicado
que han presentado a ambas partes van a
presentar una carta de desestimación del
caso en un periodo de 30 días y cuál va
a ser la cuantía de esa indemnización de
ese acuerdo económico es algo que se
desconoce que va a permanecer
confidencial aunque sí que se ha dicho
en ese comunicado que el príncipe andrés
donará a la fundación donará un dinero a
la fundación de virginia free en apoyo a
las víctimas por abuso sexual en este
comunicado los abogados del duque de
york también y cito textualmente que el
príncipe lamenta su asociación con el
fallecido multimillonario jeffrey
epstein y elogia la valentía de los
demandantes y su fuerza por denunciar
públicamente estos casos además ha dicho
que va a demostrar su arrepentimiento
apoyando a las víctimas y apoyando sus
derechos de todas estas víctimas de
tráfico y abuso sexual el jefe de la
policía de canadá renunció en medio de
las críticas por la que es calificada de
inacción contra las protestas que
paralizaron a la capital ottawa
entretanto el primer ministro de canadá
justin trudeau anunció la activación de
la ley de emergencia debido a la
situación de orden público pero qué
efecto tendrá la medida en las protestas
de anti vacunas que son minoría en
canadá veamos
el lunes el primer ministro georges team
trudeau invocó la ley de emergencia que
otorga un poder sin precedentes al
gobierno federal inversiones y la ley de
emergencias es algo que no se ha
utilizado nunca pero existe por una
razón invocar la ley de emergencias
nunca es lo primero que debe hacer un
gobierno ni siquiera lo segundo la ley
debe utilizarse con moderación y como
último recurso el padre de trudeau
pierre elliott trudeau declaró la
emergencia nacional con la ley de
medidas de guerra en respuesta al
terrorismo pero no a los disturbios de
civiles hace 50 años cuando un grupo de
separatistas de quebec secuestró a un
diplomático y a un ministro de la
provincia todo especificó que la ley
sería geográficamente específica y
limitada en el tiempo mientras los
camioneros protestan por tercera semana
contra las medidas de la pandemia en la
capital la medida de las fuerzas de
seguridad un poder más contundente para
restablecer el orden público dándoles la
autoridad de restringir los
desplazamientos prohibir las reuniones
públicas e incautar los camiones u otros
vehículos utilizados en los bloqueos en
una medida más económica el ministro de
finanzas dijo que él federal congelará
las cuentas bancarias de las personas
involucradas en las protestas ilegales y
cooperará con los poderes de recaudación
de fondos para una mayor transparencia
ya que el convoy de la libertad recaudó
millones en línea entre tanto los
camioneros parecen imperturbables
en realidad no no nos importa lo que
están haciendo en el parlamento queremos
que nos devuelvan nuestras libertades
las que teníamos en 2019
edwin el primer fin de semana y me fui a
casa y vi las noticias y escuché a turdó
mentir mintió y me molestó tanto que
dejé mi trabajo regresé y no me iré
hasta que ganemos
la declaración de emergencia entra en
vigor inmediatamente pero el parlamento
debe aprobar en el plazo de una semana
la capital de argentina buenos aires ha
sido el lugar elegido por diversas
organizaciones sociales de izquierda
para marchar en petición de mayor
asistencia social y más trabajo por
parte del gobierno la movilización llega
a días después de que el gobierno
decidiera no ampliar los planes de
empleo en el marco de la negociación del
pago de la deuda con el fmi nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires- natalio
pues hoy nos daba más temprano a los
detalles
miles de personas marchan en el centro
de la ciudad de buenos aires- en esta
protesta convocada por organizaciones
sociales no alineadas con el gobierno
nacional estas organizaciones sociales
al igual que las que son cercanas al
gobierno del presidente alberto
fernández tienen entre sus tareas la de
distribuir los planes sociales que
entregan el estado nacional algo que es
especialmente clave e importante en un
país con una pobreza que alcanza el 40
por ciento de la población en esta
marcha entre otras cosas lo que están
reclamando es más fondos para estos
planes sociales y también están mirando
a un posible acuerdo con el fondo
monetario internacional con la
desconfianza de que ese acuerdo lleve a
un ajuste un recorte en las partidas de
los planes sociales esta marcha que
también se realiza en otras partes del
país es una especie de convocatoria
previa a una más grande que se espera
para el 11 y 12 de marzo cuando también
se espera que ya se conozcan los
detalles de un eventual acuerdo con el
fondo monetario y se sepa
o no va a tocar especialmente las
partidas vinculadas con los planes
sociales el canciller alemán olaf scholz
se reunió este martes en moscú con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin desde ahí
el presidente ruso anunció la retirada
parcial de las tropas situadas cerca de
la frontera con ucrania e insistió en
que no tiene intención de ir a la guerra
scholz saludo a la noticia
las opciones diplomáticas están lejos de
estar agotadas la tarea ahora debe ser
trabajar con decisión y con valor hacia
una resolución pacífica de esta crisis
ahora estamos escuchando que algunas
tropas van a retirarse así que esa es
una buena señal esperamos que esto
continúe
estamos listos para seguir trabajando
juntos estamos listos para continuar el
camino de las negociaciones pero todas
las preguntas deben ser todos los
asuntos como dije antes deben ser
considerados como un todo gracias mateo
chof cumple la relación económica entre
alemania y rusia podría ser la clave a
la hora de solucionar el conflicto en
ucrania uno de los principales temas que
trataron los dirigentes de ambos países
fue el futuro del gasoducto nord stream
2 nuestro corresponsal en berlín
tomás sparrow pudo analizar esta
relación la visita de olaf scholz el
canciller alemán a moscú este martes fue
importante no solamente por el riesgo
que existe actualmente de una posible
guerra en europa sino también por el rol
relevante pero muy controversial que
juega alemania en toda esta situación es
un rol que tiene que ver claramente con
el vínculo económico estrecho entre
berlín y moscú y de manera muy
particular con el gasoducto nord stream
2 que ya está completado aún no está en
funciones pero une precisamente a rusia
y alemania- si vienen quienes consideran
como lo hacen varios aliados políticos
de alemania que no son dos deja
demasiado vulnerable a europa y le da
demasiado poder a moscú también hay
quienes creen que precisamente por esos
vínculos económicos estrechos alemania
puede jugar un rol clave en la búsqueda
de una solución negociada a este
conflicto esas diferentes miradas
quedaron en evidencia en la rueda de
prensa que sostuvieron olaf scholz y
vladimir putin en moscú así como también
quedaron en evidente las dos partes de
la estrategia política alemana por un
lado que alemania seguirá buscando
canales de comunicación para hablar con
rusia por ejemplo el formato de
normandía en el que francia y alemania
negocian con ucrania y con rusia pero
por el otro lado que alemania está
claramente del lado de sus aliados
políticos en la unión europea y en la
otan y que actuará en conjunto con ellos
si rusia decide invadir ucrania
por su parte el presidente de eeuu joe
biden dijo que no habría podido
verificar el anuncio de rusia que se
retiraría alguna de sus tropas de la
frontera con ucrania de forma
independiente y reiteró que defenderá a
sus aliados de una eventual invasión
rusia
no se equivoque en eeuu va a defender
todo el territorio de la otan con toda
la fuerza estadounidense un ataque
contra un miembro de la otan es un
ataque contra todos game world iron
countries guns es el parlamento etíope
levantó el martes el estado de
emergencia impuesto en noviembre de 2021
cuando los rebeldes de el tigre tomaron
dos ciudades estratégicas amenazando con
marchar hacia la capital addis abeba de
los 312 legisladores que asistieron a la
sesión 63 se opusieron al levantamiento
del estado de emergencia considerando la
medida como prematura tres meses antes
del plazo el parlamento efe puso fin al
estado de emergencia que fue declarado a
finales de 2021 cuando las fuerzas
rebeldes del chigre amenazaban con
llegar hacia la capital addis abeba la
cámara de representantes de etiopía ha
aprobado hoy el levantamiento del estado
de emergencia impuesto durante seis
meses tras rápidos avances en noviembre
la mayoría de las fuerzas rebeldes del
tigre retrocedieron y un tímido deshielo
en las relaciones entre la partes de
perfil o criticado por grupos de
derechos humanos del estado de excepción
supuso detenciones masivas de tigre
llanos en addis abeba y en el resto del
país la medida se tomó después de que
los rebeldes anunciaran haber capturado
las ciudades estratégicas de de 100 y
con bolsa en la región de amara e
indicarán que podrían avanzar más al sur
hacia adis abeba pero desde entonces
ambas ciudades volvieron al control del
gobierno
etiopía es un país dividido en 10
regiones cada una representa a
diferentes grupos étnicos con cierta
autonomía el tlf que gobierna la región
del tigre dirigió el país con mano dura
durante casi 30 años antes de ser
derrocado por protestas masivas hoy los
rebeldes acusan al primer ministro había
ahmad de haberlos excluidos de los
órganos del gobierno central y de querer
someterlos en noviembre de 2020 ahmed
envió al ejército contra los rebeldes
del chigre a quienes acusó de atacar
bases militares
desde entonces el conflicto deja miles
de muertos más de 2 millones de
desplazados y otros miles de choques al
borde de la hambruna según las naciones
unidas
hasta aquí este repaso a la actualidad
internacional les invitamos a seguir
conectados a france 24 y ampliar toda
esta información y mucho más en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom
[Música]